[Music]
phoner performance and equipment
advanced research facility is designed
to evaluate soldier performance under
various load configurations and also
different types of cognitive loading a
lot of the research that we do here is
looking at the interaction of physical
and cognitive performance the device
that we're evaluating is meant to
augment the soldier's ability to carry
load so it's not trying to look for them
but it's reducing some of the muscle
strain and physiologic work that they
have to do the suit is designed to
assist in the push-off phase of gait as
your foot your heel comes off the ground
and your toe is pushing off the muscle
on the back of your calf contracts and
the muscles on the back of your hip also
are swinging your leg forward so what
the system does is it pulls at the back
of the thigh in the back of the foot at
the same time that your muscles are
working and the idea is that it's
creating that motion so that your
muscles don't have to do the work it's
like a rubber band when you can feel the
tension but when you take it step helps
to pull your leg up we have been walking
on the treadmill for five minutes and
while they're doing that they're
performing a cognitive task to see if
when they come back from the pull on
load carriage it's helped them be less
fatigued so they were better able to
perform that task the load carried for
this protocol is 75 pounds and that that
was the rucksack the weapon that they
were carrying in the body armor that
they were wearing the system weighs
about 20 pounds on top of that
it's mass that they're wearing we're
using to evaluate the energy expenditure
the system is connected to reports the
oxygen and carbon dioxide concentrations
of the air they're inhaling and exhaling
and then gives us a calculation of the
calories they're burning they were
looking for a reduction of 25% in
metabolic cost if we see anything over
5% we consider that meaningful that's
within the tolerance of our system